hey guys merry here with a gamespot news
update shockingly enough money wins it
turns out Bethesda hasn't given up on
paid mods for Skyrim in April Bethesda
and valve allowed modders to sell their
creations and profit off of them for a
variety of reasons this move was met
with controversy it only lasted a couple
of days before valve pulled them off
steam saying in a statement it's become
clear we don't know exactly what we're
doing in an interview with gamespot
Bethesda's VP of Marketing Pete Hines
said that they'd like to reevaluate the
system because modders should be able to
monetize the split used in April was
forty-five percent for bethesda 34 valve
and twenty-five percent for modders
which according to Hines is the industry
standard although Bethesda is interested
in returning to paid mods Hines said not
to expect anything soon in part because
of the impending release of Fallout 4 he
said honestly we have bigger fish to fry
right now than sorting that out so with
the announcement that mods are coming to
console for Fallout 4 it's not too
surprising that Bethesda would want to
monetize them and get that forty five
percent cut but do you think modders
deserve more than a quarter for every
dollar for the latest on gamespot news
be sure to head to gamespot com
you